Hey Thoughty2 here.
Most children in the West are brought up being
told that a jolly fat magic man delivers their
presents every year.
But as we grow older and wiser we start to
think that that maybe isn’t the whole truth
and the disappearing mince pie and brandy
has a lot more to do with your actual father
than Father Christmas.
But naysayers I’m here to present a different
point of view, and go with me on this one.
What if Santa Claus, is real?
Well he could be.
And I’m not talking about magic but actual
science.
What happens when we apply maths, formulas
and the laws of motion to a large man with
a brandy addiction?
But surely it’s impossible for one man to
deliver millions of presents to millions of
homes in just one night?
Not to mention the flying reindeer and sweat-shop
elves.
Well depending on how naughty you’ve been
this year, you might be pleasantly surprised…
let’s take a look at the actual physics
behind Santa Claus and find out if we shouldn’t
be so quick to disbelieve in a very old Christmas
legend.
So one of the major issues people have with
the big K. Kringle is that he couldn’t possibly
visit every house on Earth in one night.
But the thing is he doesn’t have to.
To start, he reportedly only visits children,
of which there are 2 billion of on Earth,
that’s people under the age of 18.
The average children per household across
the world is roughly 3.5.
So that leaves 1 billion households for Santa
to visit on Christmas Eve.
It’s commonly been accepted throughout history
that Santa doesn’t visit children of non-Christian
religions such as Muslim, Jewish, Hindu and
Buddhist.
So if we factor out those households that
leaves us with only 92 million homes for Santa
to visit, that’s significantly less.
Also Santa doesn’t have to fit all these
into just 24 hours on Christmas eve.
If he travels from East to West he would have
31 hours in which to deliver presents, thanks
to timezone differences.
This leaves Santa with roughly 1/1000th of
a second to get down the chimney, deliver
presents and consume whatever treats have
been left out for him.
He would have to make 822 visits per second.
A challenge indeed.
And that brings us to the ever so complicated
topic of flying reindeer.
There are an estimated 300,000 species of
living organisms yet to be classified, and
there exists a bleedin snake that can fly,
so who are we to say there aren’t flying
reindeer somewhere out there.
But one of the biggest obstacles stopping
Santa from being real is not magical deer
but the payload he would have to carry.
Even if every child only received a small
toy from Santa, around 800g on average, it
would result in a payload on Santa’s Sleigh
weighting 302 million kilograms.
And that’s not even counting all the coal
for all the horrible little terrors.
Now consider that Santa would have to travel
at 650 miles per second to get around all
the required households in time for Christmas
morning.
302 million kilograms traveling at that speed
would exert a red-nose shattering 13.5 quintillion
joules of energy on each reindeer, due to
the immense air pressure created at such speeds.
At those pressures Blitzen’s going to get
blitzed and Comet will turn into an actual
comet.
In short, Santa, his sleigh and his reindeer
would burst into a ball of flames and perish
instantaneously after setting off from the
North Pole.
Soo yeah..
Merry Christmas!
But hold on kids, wipe away those tears, because
Thoughty2 backed up by some scientific papers
he read, is about to save Christmas.
The strange science of Quantum mechanics allows
for some physics defying spectacles that seem
to defy every scientific law you know.
And if we apply the laws of Quantum mechanics
to Santa Claus then it’s possible that he
is a Macroscopic Quantum Object.
This would allow him to be in multiple places
at once – meaning he could deliver presents
to every child on Earth simultaneously.
There’s also the added benefit that he can
keep and eye on Mrs. Claus whilst he’s away
for the night.
Which is imperative after “Elf Gate” of
Christmas Eve 1984.
Quantum mechanics is a branch of science that
studies the very, very small; subatomic particles.
It is our current understanding that these
tiny particles, such as electrons can be in
two or more places in the universe at the
exact same time, as long as nobody is watching.
To prove this, scientists fired a single particle
into an opaque plate that had two slits in
it.
The diffraction pattern on the other side
of the plate revealed that this singular particle
actually passed through both slits at the
same time.
However, when detectors were setup to monitor
if the particle passed through each slit,
it only passed through one slit at a time,
but never both.
Just because it was being watched.
To put it as simply as possible, this happens
because the particle’s wavefunction collapses
when it is being observed, so it can no longer
be in two places at once.
It’s similar to how Mrs. Claus can be in
a different place than she’s supposed to
be, when Santa’s not watching.
This explains why Santa Claus can never be
seen, because if he were his wavefunction
would collapse.
So if this is true how come we know Santa
as a large jolly fellow and not an iddy-biddy
little subatomic particle?
Well scientists have observed large clusters
of particles that seem to behave as one single
particle, admittedly these clusters of particles
are nowhere near as large as our prospective
Mr Claus, but have some imagination for goodness
sake.
So if Santa and his reindeer are a cluster
of billions and billions of particles, acting
together as one – he could theoretically
still adhere to the laws of quantum mechanics
and deliver lovely gifts to deserving children
all over the world, in just one night.
This would also explain why his super secret
Bond-villain, death star base of toy-construction
is tucked away in the North Pole.
Because quantum particles only behave in this
manner in very, very cold environments.
Scientists have only observed the behavior
at close to absolute zero; minus 273 C, which
is somewhat colder than the north pole.
But then, we have to allow for some magic
at Christmas, don’t we?
Thanks for the view.